you
Oh
Oh Chrissy William and I'll be your host
for tonight and tonight we are going to
learn how astronomers map the universe
and what those maps can reveal you see
in a broad sense astronomy is all about
understanding our place in the universe
our place in space and our place in time
and it's only recently that we've really
begun to understand where we actually
are in 1924 Edwin Hubble showed that
Andromeda is a galaxy in its own right
and therefore that the universe is much
larger than the Milky Way alone five
years later he proved that the universe
is expanding and therefore that it had
an origin in time we now know that at
origin was 13.8 billion years ago but
how did we get from that hot dense
primordial soup of the Big Bang to the
astounding complexity that we see around
us today to understand how the universe
has evolved we have to map that
complexity tonight dr. Daniel Eisenstein
will tell us about an ambitious project
known as the Sloan Digital Sky Survey it
has created the largest 3d map of the
universe ever made with that map we are
learning how dark matter and dark energy
have influenced the past and will guide
the future of the cosmos and as with any
map it begins with a little dot saying
you are here
please welcome director of the Sloan
Digital Sky Survey 3 Daniel Eisenstein
well I want to thank everybody for
coming out tonight it's really a great
to see such an enthusiastic crowd and
I'm going to be telling you about the
work that we do in the Sloan Digital Sky
Survey are really a portion of the work
that we do in the Sloan Digital Sky
Survey focusing on this phenomena of
dark energy and trying to tell you some
about how we try to map it which
involves this sort of fabulous events in
the early universe involving large sound
waves so the outline of the talk i'm
going to give you an introduction to
cosmology and dark energy just giving
you some some basics then i'll introduce
this idea of what's called the baryon
acoustic oscillations these sound waves
that we use as a cosmic yardstick and
then I'll be telling about the Sloan
Digital Sky Survey I'll try to go
through a fair bit of detail on how we
actually go about doing these
observations then I'll tell you about
our detections of this effect in the
sdss and tell you some of what we've
learned about cosmology from that so
let's get started with with the big
pictures of cosmology so the real I
think primal question here is what's the
universe made of so of course the
composition of the universe is a very
basic question of physics and as you may
well know this is something that's
turned out to have very surprising
answers the first set of surprises were
these ideas of dark matter so when
astronomers started measuring the
motions of stars in our own galaxy or in
other galaxies or the motions of
galaxies within clusters of galaxies
they found that these stars and galaxies
were orbiting the out there there there
center too quickly and this indicated
there must be more mass there that's
holding these these objects onto bound
orbits these days we can actually see
this quite directly with gravitational
lensing this is a cluster of galaxies LT
all the yellow objects are clusters of
galaxies and they're actually bending
the light of a galaxy in the background
this is the same galaxy seen four times
being bent by the light of the galaxy so
from this we can quite directly infer
the amount of mass that must be in this
cluster and it's much larger than what
the stars would
would provide and at the great surprise
is that this extra matter this dark
matter is not just more of us it's not
just more protons or or electrons or
whatnot it actually has to have some
exotic form and we've been able to show
that fairly directly well having
discovered dark matter in the context of
galaxies and clusters of galaxies
astronomers set out to try to measure
the total amount of dark matter in the
universe and to do that we need to
measure the motions on even larger
scales and the most extreme version of
this is to try to measure the
gravitational effect on the expansion of
the universe itself Christine just
mentioned that that we've known for
almost a hundred years that the universe
is expanding but if you have a universe
that has more matter on it than you
would imagine you'd expect that that
expansion would slow down over time
because of the action of gravity and the
by measuring the amount of that
deceleration you would infer the amount
of the amount of material well I should
pause to just give you a little bit of a
sense of of the expanding of what it
means to measure expansion so we're
using Doppler shifts to measure how fast
galaxies are moving away and these
Doppler shifts are really exactly like
what you get when you know when a police
car is coming toward you're away from
you hear that you hear the sound change
in our case we're looking for the
transition of particular atomic
transitions in the spectra of galaxies
and watching them shift in wavelength
towards the red this allows us to
measure how fast the galaxies are moving
away from us and in a uniform expanding
universe then you expect that galaxies
that are further away from us
intrinsically are moving away faster
basically this is as if you know we all
stood up and you know instead of sitting
seat to seat next to each other we all
stood up and had to put one spare seat
between us in this room that would be
hard right now but you would then see
that if you get to get your neighbor to
move wait your neighbor only has to move
one seat but somebody at the other side
of the room has to effectively move 20
seats because we got to stick in an
extra seat between every pair of people
so this relationship between the
velocity of a galaxy and the distance is
called Hubble relation and for small
distances this gives us a way of
measuring the relative distance to
objects
now this recession velocity is also
known as a redshift and it's written as
the letter Z and so I will very often
say the word redshift in this talk and
what I mean is this recessional velocity
the word redshift comes into our to our
lingo so much because redshift is when
you when you measure an object that's
moving away from us very quickly it's
very far from us this means that the
light has taken a very long time to get
to us and that means that object was
that light was emitted very early in the
universe or earlier in the universe so
the measurement of redshift is also a
measurement of the time that that you're
viewing that object that when you when
you observe a Galaxy at higher redshift
you're observing a portion of the
universe that is younger and that's a
very important thing alright well let's
try to connect this idea to how we're
actually trying to weigh the universe so
here's a very simple plot of the size of
the universe vs time and we're here at
the present day and at the present size
and at the universe we're just expanding
ballistically if there was no forces on
anything you know things would just move
inertially and you'd have a linear
relationship between the size and the
time and you would look back and say oh
the Big Bang is 14 billion years ago but
if you think that the universe is
decelerating because of matter then in
fact it should be expanding quicker at
the beginning and then it should start
to decelerate and that means that you
that that the the Big Bang the time of
zero size is is less time in the past so
that would say that objects that a given
redshift should actually appear to be
closer because they've traveled less
that blights traveled less distance to
get to us that means the objects would
be a little bit brighter so you would
expect that by measuring objects at a
given redshift if you measure them to be
a little bit the brighter you measure
them to be the more deceleration there
has been and therefore the more mass
there is in the universe and the great
discovery in 1998 from two teams
studying high redshift supernovae was
that the supernova actually appeared to
be too faint they were not too bright
they were too faint and they interpreted
this as not as the idea that the
universe is not decelerating but
accelerating this is a completely
bizarre idea because gravity does not
you know gravity wants to pull on things
and yet somehow
on the largest scales our universe
appears to be getting pushed apart so we
label this as dark energy so it's some
unknown thing filling space I actually
usually joke that dark energy actually
over States our knowledge by a factor of
two because all we really know is that
it's dark we don't actually know its
energy but if you believe that its
energy then it's actually out weighing
all the rest of the matter in the
universe by about a factor of two so
here's here's just referring to this
picture if you observe the objects if
you think the universe is accelerating
then it decelerates initially and then
dark energy starts to turn on and you
actually get an acceleration at late
times and so you find that the
accelerating universe you have the
photons have traveled farther longer to
get to us that traveled further and
therefore objects appear to be fainter
so we're left with this idea of a cosmic
composition where we are here in the
atoms part of the pie only four percent
of the pie and in fact the stars are
only about point only about half a
percent so most of the gas is not even
in stars most of the atom Martin stars
but then we have dark matter which is
out laying the atoms by six to one and
we have dark energy which is outweighing
the matter by about a factor of two so
what's the cause of this well they've
been many possible explanations advanced
for dark energy the most famous of which
is the cosmological constant that
Einstein actually introduced an effort
to try to make the universe basically
standstill he wanted to basically
balance the universe of the
gravitational forces and this is outward
going force what exactly balance of the
universe with stace would stay static we
now know that's not the case and that's
why he labeled it his biggest blunder
but so might be the cosmological
constant it might be that we have some
new force in the universe we know about
the electro electro magnetic force the
weak nuclear force the strong nuclear
force and gravity maybe we've just
discovered the fifth force and that it's
actually some some repulsive force on
the very largest scales or maybe we just
don't understand one of the normal
forces maybe we misunderstand gravity
and we like to think that gravity is
always pulling on things but maybe on
the largest scales it actually pushes
stuff up pushes stuff around ah maybe
this is some you know remnants
of string theory that certain theory
says things should behave in ten
dimensions maybe that when it comes down
to our scales actually causes some
bizarre acceleration on the largest
scales and this list could go on and on
and on and there are shelf feet of
journal devoted to trying to explain
dark energy and I think unfortunately
all of these X all these explanations
have some exotic or vexing aspect to
them and so you know there's no there's
no one theory that's so aesthetically
compelling that everybody agrees that
that's probably the right explanation
basically if that's the proponents of
the theory they all love their their
children but but to get them to love
other people's children not so much so
so what can we do observational e well
the main thing we try to do is measure
very accurate distances so I said that
the supernovae were measured to be too
faint that means they're too distant and
we're trying to measure extremely
accurate distances we want to do this to
have order one percent now this is very
challenging because throughout those
second half of the 20th century
astronomers were arguing about something
called the Hubble constant and they
argued about whether was fifty or a
hundred in some particular units and so
there's a factor of two disagreement in
the distance scale universe people
actually were disagreeing on what on how
far away the galaxies were by the factor
of two level and we're now doing this at
one percent so how do we do this well
we're doing it with something called the
baryon acoustic oscillations so this in
brief I will explain this in much more
detail in the slides coming up but in
brief sound waves that propagate in the
first 400,000 years after the Big Bang
so very early on these sound waves
create a very distinctive feature in the
clustering of galaxies and that feature
is that pairs of galaxies if I have two
galaxies they are slightly more likely
to be separated by 500 million light
years then by then they are by 400 or
600 million light years so there's a
characteristic scale of the clustering
of pairs of galaxies that's imprinted in
the early universe and when we get to
see this scale then we get to infer
distances because if I tell you that I'm
six feet tall you just get to break out
a protractor and measure what the angle
is from my head to my feet as it appears
to you and then you can infer the
distance from me to you so just by
telling you how tall I am
and allowing you to measure angles you
can measure distance so that's the idea
this is called a standard ruler and
that's that's how we use this okay so
let's uh let's start trying to explain
these sound waves well we're going to
start with the Cosmic Microwave
Background so the Cosmic Microwave
Background is the radiation the relic
heat left over from the Big Bang and to
call it heat might sound ambitious even
for Bostonians because this is only
three degrees above absolute zero so
this is a relic heat left over three
degrees above absolute zero and but it's
incredibly useful because this radiation
has traveled to us basically unimpeded
through throughout the history of the
universe from a time only 400,000 years
after the Big Bang and this is a picture
of the microwave background this is now
projection on the sky and you can see
the early universe was exceptionally
boring very very simple place very very
homogeneous well when you turn up the
contrast if you take that picture and
you now try to focus in on tiny details
instead of looking at three degree
blackbody differences you're now looking
at 3 milli kelvins so three pardon a
thousand variations in this map and now
you start to see some behavior you see
that one's got is part of the sky is a
part in a thousand hotter than the other
part of the sky in the other direction
this is actually caused because we are
moving relative to the microwave
background so when you move then you
bend the parts that you're moving toward
gets a little bit of a Doppler boost it
appears to be a little bit hotter the
parts are moving away from gets a
Doppler you know recession and looks a
little bit colder that's basically
boring again because that's only about
us that's telling how we are moving it's
not telling us anything about what the
rest of the universe is doing to see how
the rest of the universe is doing is to
turn up the contrast by another factor
of 100 and this was the great discovery
by the cobe satellite that when you
finally blow up the contrast by now part
in 100,000 so we're now looking at 30
microkelvin variations in a three degree
back background then you actually do see
ripples in this map and these ripples
are coming to us from the very early
universe is a picture of the density
fluctuations on a thin shell 400,000
years after the Big Bang 13.7
million years from us so we're looking
at a gigantic sphere 13.7 billion years
in radius and you're looking at the
density fluctuations along that sphere
well that was the map as we had in 1992
and since then people have been working
very hard to try to improve this and a
major step forward was the W
mapsatellite this was the picture now uh
in 20 in 2003 and in this past a couple
years we now have the new map from the
satellite called plunk which improving
the resolution more and more and more so
these fluctuations are tiny only a part
100,000 but they're incredibly important
because the details of these little
ripples are actually telling us about
the composition of the very early
universe and about a fair number other
things as well but they're really
exceptional for measuring composition so
let's try to understand that well now
we're going to get into this idea of the
acoustic oscillations so if I look at
this map from the W map case when you
look at the temperature fluctuations you
see fluctuations on large angular scales
you know there's you know this region is
a little hotter than that region for
example and you see fluctuations on
small angular skills but if you take a
just a part of this map and you blow it
up and you just look at it your eye is
drawn to a characteristic scale of the
blob enos there is sort of it there is a
scale in this map a sort of typical size
of the blobs and that is not caused by
the resolution of the telescope that's
actually caused by very important
physical process in the early universe
so the way that we analyze maps like
this is by taking them and splitting
them up into into their wavelengths so
basically we're trying to split them up
into the long wavelength modes the
medium wavelength modes on the short
wavelength modes and plotting how much
variation there is as a function of mode
so it's like taking a piece of music and
trying to figure out how much of the
volume is in low see how much is in
middle e how much is in high G and
plotting that up so this was the the
picture that came from the wmf satellite
of this big bump at one degree angular
scale so this was this characteristic
scale your eyes picking out a one degree
sort of dominant frequency in the map
and you also see harmonics at
this and if this picture looks too
impressionistic this is the picture from
but from the plot data one two three
four five six seven and if you squint at
the yellow points the eighth and maybe
the ninth p so these are basically
overtones of this fundamental scale in
the early universe you're seeing you're
seeing our harmonic you're seeing a
fundamental mode and then of the
harmonics of it much like if you have an
organ pipe you get the fundamental mode
of the organ pipe and then you can get
overtones of that mode so what's causing
this so this is these are actually
caused by sound waves that propagate in
the early universe now the key idea here
is this idea of recombination it happens
at redshift of a thousand so when the
universal a thousand times smaller than
it is today a billion times denser a
thousand times hotter and this is
400,000 years after the Big Bang this
this age I'm talking about okay why is
this important well it's important
because prior to this time the universe
is sufficiently hot and dense that it's
actually ionized so all the atoms have
had their electrons plucked off so you
have basically electrons and free nuclei
floating around instead of neutral
instead of neutral gas this is very
important because free electrons are
extremely good at scattering photons if
you try to send a photon through such a
medium and immediately scatters around
if the atoms in this room we're all of a
sudden to become ionized into a plasma
aside from all the other horrible things
that would happen to us we would not be
able to see each other so the light the
light would bounce around very quickly
now the reason this is so important is
if you now take a packet of this gas is
plasma and you squeeze it down the
photons are trapped inside and much like
if you take a piston and try to compress
a piston it heats up the gas it heats up
the photons and those photons are
providing an enormous amount of
radiation pressure bow to pressure
protons a light actually does push on
things and so as you take this gas and
squeeze it the photons are getting
higher and higher pressure and
eventually they don't like the
compression is actually going to push
back out and it will overshoot and
become too cold and the rest and the
rest universe then pushes back so the
whole thing will just sit there and
oscillate this is exactly the behavior
of a sound wave it's really exactly like
the sound waves that are propagating in
this room the only difference
is that in this room this restoring
pressure is the random motion of the
molecules in the gas whereas in the
early universe the pressure is dominated
by the radiation pressure of the photons
but aside from that they're just sound
waves so this is very important this
means that that all perturbations that
get set up in the early universe from
inflation are just sitting there
jiggling as sound waves this process
comes to a dramatic halt after
recombination at recombination the
universe has cooled enough that the that
the electrons bind on to the nuclei
forming a neutral gas just like in this
room now photons can travel just fine
again like this room so now if you take
a pack of this gas and you squeeze it
the photons leave and the gas just
settles in more and more and more
because of gravity gravity is just going
to take over and it's going to pull it
in and try to form galaxies and clusters
see if this major transition in the
early universe where it goes from being
stabilized through these through to out
Neal Weber all perturbations oscillate a
sound wave to a situation where
perturbations of the gas try to run away
and have run away collapse because of
gravity so very major change so let's
see why this matters for us so let's
imagine a toy case where we just imagine
a smooth universe that happens to be
over dance at a single location and it's
over dense and dark matter it's over
dancing gas / dance and neutrinos /
dents and photons and because it's over
dense in photons it's also
over-pressured this is coming out of
coming out of the first second after the
Big Bang with inflation you'll get a
region that's over pressured and the way
that an overpressure tries will
equilibrate is by driving a spherical
sound wave outwards this is really you
know if I have a balloon that's over
pressured and all of a sudden I popped
the balloon you'll hear it but you'll
hear it because a sound wave travels out
from the balloon to you so the wave
travels out at the speed of sound which
at these early times is fantastically
large fifty-seven percent of the speed
of light it's a relativistic sound way
of traveling outwards that's because the
radiation pressure is really strong and
it will travel out until you get to this
epoch of recombination at that time the
universe becomes neutral
photons separate from the gas and that
means that the sound speed in the gas
drops enormously and the wave stalls so
you have this wave going out in the gas
it goes out for a certain distance and
then at 400,000 years after the Big Bang
it halts well at that point the universe
is expanding so wherever that's gel halt
has halted it will now be carried along
with the expansion of the universe and
it will expand out to a distance that
today is 150 megaparsecs or in more
conventional units 500 million light
years so we have this this
characteristic scale of 500 million
light years why does this matter well
because we have the dark matter at the
center that will preferentially attract
material in form galaxies and we have
this extra gas at a shell of 500 million
light years and that will preferentially
collect material and form extra galaxies
and so you predict that pairs of
galaxies if you have one galaxy at the
center you will have a slightly
increased chance of having another
galaxy somewhere out on that shell 500
million light years away so pairs of
galaxies are slightly more likely to be
separated by 500 million light years
than they are by 400 or 600 million
light years okay well that's a
distinctive and why do we you know how
do we go to why is it so useful it's
useful because this distance of 500
million light-years is very easy to
compute it's really just the sound speed
and the amount of time it has to
propagate and it turns out that the CMB
and I satrapies allow us to measure all
the properties that are needed to
compute this and so we can determine we
can calculate this scale of 500 million
light-years very accurately with the
latest data we know the scale
two-point-three percent so this is very
unusual in astronomy we're in astronomy
we we are very it's very well in most
cases you don't know how big something
is intrinsically if you look at a galaxy
you don't know intrinsically how big it
is or how luminous it is but this is a
particular property that the early
universe gives us that we actually are
able to calibrate its size
two-point-three percent at that point we
can use it in a stand as a standard
ruler measuring its angular extent not
only in the microwave background data
although that's a beautiful measurement
but also in low redshift data
of galaxy surveys and that allows us to
measure distance as a function of
redshift which was our key path to
measuring dark energy all right so I
explained the universe that was over
dense at a single location initially in
fact the universe is perturbed at all
locations all locations amid their
spherical Soundwave and so you don't get
to see bullseye patterns in the in the
data instead you're going to see some
pattern and overlaid on it in some
complicated way is these you know 500
million Lightyear echoes but it turns
out that we can measure that well I'll
explain how we do it in a minute but the
you know the challenge is that you need
very large maps of the universe's a
subtle effect you know only a
one-percent little extra extra hiccup at
500 million light years 500 million
light years is a big scale even for us
and so we need to have very large maps
to do it okay so now I'll start telling
you about how we map the universe so the
the primary way that we do this is by
using galaxies so we want to use
galaxies as signposts pecially measure
the three-dimensional location of
galaxies and from that infer the density
of material across the universe so you
start by measuring two-dimensional maps
so you measure you just take pictures of
the sky and you can find the galaxies
the problem is when you see those
galaxies you don't know which galaxies
are very luminous galaxies far away and
which galaxies are smaller wimpier
galaxies really close to you so you need
to be able to tell the difference and
the way that you tell the difference is
what spectroscopy the more distant
galaxies we are going to have larger
Doppler velocities larger red shifts and
so you can sort the galaxies as a
function of distance by using their
velocity you don't know the scale on it
you don't know the scale on the distance
but you at least get to sort them the
largest maps use about a million
galaxies and this is a picture of it
from the sdss where you know we are here
and this is looking at in red shift so
this is let's see that's a two billion
light years away sup 2 billion years and
you can see the large-scale structure
this is just sort of a swath across the
sky so you can see that the universe has
a lot of clustering and we're now
looking for a subtle effect on top of
that
this subject has a very long history at
the Center for Astrophysics the center
patricks was really involved with a lot
of the earliest developments in this
field most famously the stick man and
Great Wall discovered by Margaret Geller
John Cochran Valerie tulle area and so
it's a it's really fun to be able to
pursue this work here but I'll be
telling about the sdss the sdss is the
world's largest galaxy redshift survey
we use a dedicated telescope two and a
half meter telescope in New Mexico it's
above Alamogordo if you've been New
Mexico the project actually got started
in nineteen ninety so it's 25 years old
this year we started taking data in 1998
which means that our first data can
actually now apply for driver's licenses
and it's still running we're we're
running through at least the end of this
decade it's the world's largest
compilation of astronomical spectroscopy
it's about four million astronomical
objects it's been generously supported
over the years by the sloan Foundation
Department of Energy National Science
Foundation and over 50 member
institutions we now have about a
thousand people in the collaboration
it's really been a wonderful
collaboration to be a part of there's
lots of different interests scientists
from all around the world come together
to work on this project trying to blend
their skills together and it's really
set the culture of astronomy in many
different ways it's been it's been
really a wonderful experience to be
involved with okay so this is the
telescope that we have does somebody
want to tell me an unusual aspect of the
telescope it's square yes there's petals
on the top yes and there's no dome so
normally use normally used to seeing
telescopes inside of a dome we actually
park this telescope in a building the
building rolls off and leaves the
telescope out in the open air so this
telescope it's a two and half meter
telescope not a particularly large
telescope bye-bye research standards but
it is unusual because it has such a wide
field of view so it for these sorts of
wide field surveys it actually is really
one of the most powerful telescopes in
the world what you see here is the boxy
structure is actually not connect
into the telescope it's actually a wind
it's actually a windscreen that keep the
wind off the telescope and when the
telescope moved the telescope's inside
this and when the telescope moves the
windscreen automatically moves around to
track so the first thing that we do is
we take we took images of the sky so
this telescope conducted really one of
the largest imaging campaigns when you
look in google sky or microsoft
worldwide telescope at the most most
areas of the northern sky the image that
you're seeing is generally from sdss
here's an entirely not random picture
that we took at the telescope this is
m51 here's a globular cluster m13
basically imaging the sky using digital
techniques in five different band passes
here's a nice interacting pair of
galaxies galaxies group and we repeated
this for take a total of eight years
nine years actually conducting a big
survey of the sky so this is a picture
now of the North Galactic cap so the
galaxy the Milky Way would be around the
edge here and this is looking out
towards the Galactic Pole and this is
this picture is unusual because we've
actually removed all the Starlight we've
got into the images and removed all the
stars and all you're seeing here is the
integrated light from the galaxies and
in this you can already start to see
some large-scale structure these sort of
lumps aren't and you know darker spots
or not that's not just chance there's
there actually are large-scale
structures but these are the structures
that are nearby and you can see how much
harder is to measure structure in this
two-dimensional map compared to the
three-dimensional map that I that I
showed you earlier we also work at the
part of the southern sky that we can see
from New Mexico so you can tip over in
certain times of the year and see part
of the southern sky and all told we
imaged about a third of the sky and all
this data has been released to the
public as a 2010 it's really a
phenomenal amount of data so if you just
take a little chunk of this this and
blow it up to some not randomly chosen
region and then blow it up again and
then blow it up again and you can I
don't think from where you are you can
actually get see the detail in the
picture overall told it's a trillion
multicolored pixels so it's a trillion
pixel map of the of the sky
but we then want to continue and try to
map in three dimensions I've shown you
this picture before we want to measure
spectra and spectroscopy is much more
expensive because instead of just
measuring collecting the light from an
object we're now trying to collect the
light and split it up into a rainbow and
measure a thousand independent colors of
that rainbow and so we need much more
light in order to do that and so we can
only do it on on certain subsets of the
objects in until about nineteen ninety
all the spectroscopy has done one object
at a time you basically would sit there
and do one object one object one object
well it takes a long time to get for up
to four million if you're doing what
object to the time and so what we do is
something called fiber spectroscopy so
basically these are optical fibers and
they plug into this plate and the light
will go into those fibers and then
transmitted off to the off to the
telescope so I brought a couple place
here but you can you can see so this is
a this is a plate that would go at the
at the focal plane of the telescope so
basically the light would bounce off the
primary mirror bounced up to the
secondary and come down and and you know
come to this come to focus at this
location if this plate were covered with
photographic film then when exposed to
the sky you would actually get an image
of the sky it here it would not be the
whole sky be you know a chunk of the sky
about six full moons across so about
three degrees across and you get an
image of the sky we then we take that
image and we are then interested in some
particular particular subsets of objects
there would be about how do we would
detect about a hundred thousand objects
on this chunk of sky this big and we
only have resource to take spectra of a
thousand of them so we select which
thousand we want and then at the
location where the light is from those
thousand objects is going to fall we go
when we drill a hole at that location
and we will plug an optical fiber in
that and that means when the light comes
down there it's going to get it's going
to get trapped into that fiber and run
off to the telescope's I'm going to pass
this round I have to up I'll pass around
and I want to warn you it's you cannot
hurt it I promise there's nothing you
can do that will hurt this plate but it
can't hurt the head of the person in
front of you it has these little flanges
it weighs more than you think so
so do be careful with your neighbors but
not but don't worry about being careful
at the plate so let me just say a few
words more about about the plates so the
fibers themselves I should be careful
I'm probably knocking my little
microphone the fibers themselves are
only a hundred and twenty microns thick
so they're about the thickness of a
human hair the holes that you see in
this plate are considerably thicker than
that becomes considerably bigger than
that that's because the fiber is
actually held for safety in a little
metal tube at the end to give somebody
you know that something something to
hold onto they can actually plug the
fiber in if you just tried to plug a
little you know your hair into it a
brittle hair into it it would break and
the survey would be over very quickly so
we have to protect the fibers the fibers
are actually you know they're in these
these orange tubes but again that's just
for their protection the holes
themselves are drilled to about 10
micron precision so it's actually this
this these these plates look simple but
they're actually they're very precisely
machined because we have to get the
light in just the right spot and when we
have so I should also mention them that
so they're actually a hand plugged so
this is obviously sped up it takes about
an hour to plug a plate um you might
wonder how we get how we know which
fiber went into which hole it's very
clever we actually run a fibers are all
running off to a to a sort of a
one-dimensional slit head they're all
kind of full incoming to one dimensions
we actually shine a laser we actually
run a laser down illuminating one fiber
at a time and you watch each individual
whole light up in sequence and you
record that with a video camera so you
know which which order the holes the
whole / plug you'll see little lines on
the plate the lines all the lines each
region contains twenty fibers because
the fibers can't stretch all the way
across the plate so if you were just
plugging anywhere you wanted you would
you would inevitably end up with the
last hole over here in the last fiber
over here and
you'd have to start over so you actually
grab 25 hours at a time plug 25 hours
grab the next 20 plug 25 hours that
keeps you organized as you move across
the plate so let me start this off you
also notice it's big and heavy that's
because it has been really stiff so the
focal surface is only about you know a
few hundred microns thick so you really
have to have the plate really in the
right location and if you tip the
telescope over if it was floppy or week
it would you know the gravity sag would
cause problems so you really have to
hold it in the right spot so they're
plugged by our dedicated workers at
Apache point in one month in 2011 we had
a really clear month we plugged a
hundred thousand fibers so all right
well wins when the when the plates all
done being plugged it goes off to the
back of the telescope this is actually
the camera the camera comes off the
plate goes on and it sticks into these
two spectrographs here this is probably
easier more easily seen in this movie so
it's just trying to give you a feel for
for what we do at the observatory so
this is the telescope over here one of
the observers is going to load one of
these cartridges these plates actually
sit in these crushes they weigh about
300 pounds trying to hold things they're
really really stiff so you can't move
around by hand you have to have
mechanical aid it's the bond of the
telescope so he's going to wheel the
cartridge in lower the last cartridge
back up insert the next cartridge take
it back and load this things up so
there's the building rolling off we're
getting ready for the night's observer
this is on a mountain that eighty and
ninety two hundred feet in New Mexico
looking out over white sands national
monument if ever been to white sands you
were actually very close to the
telescope and basically we're really on
the west edge of the mountain range so
the hope is that when the prevailing
winds come over they're basically coming
over this valley for 50 miles nothing to
stir up the air and we hope that the
first thing that air encounters after 50
miles over the valley is our telescope
so nothing else has been able to stir up
the air so this is now the sort of time
lapse ting over the night I'll so skip
ahead but but basically you know load up
the plate observe a given spot on the
sky for about an hour and when you're
done then they're done the plate we
basically we only use the plate for an
hour so we've we've now drilled about
7000 of these plates over the years to
keep the survey moving okay so let's try
to look at some of the data so this is
now it's gonna be a movie of sort of
flying through a big chunk of this
three-dimensional map it's hard to show
3d maps so this is now showing sort of a
thin slice of the map and I'm going to
move that slice along I'm picking the
slice to be at a given distance from us
so as the movie progresses this black
swath will move out and that's going to
correspond to the thin slice moving out
through the survey this is a fixed angle
on the sky this is about twenty percent
of the survey volume about twenty
percent the air so it's about four
percent of the sky so I'm showing you
basically four percent of the sky and
then just a slice going out from us to
make the map a little bit dynamic i
start the objects off when they enter
into the thin slice i'll start them off
faint and red and then break them up to
black and then dim them out to faint in
blue so you'll see things move around as
you as we go through you'll see though
you'll basically slicing through the
large scale walls and filaments and
voids at the University you can actually
see the large-scale structure of the
universe the black circle here has a
radius of 500 million light years so
that's our characteristic scale as the
movie plays you'll see that gets smaller
because you're moving further away
you're looking at a slice that's further
away from us so that scale will appear
to be angularly smaller you'll also see
the large-scale structure the voids and
patterns will actually appear to get
smaller that's because they're further
away from you are actually seeing them
seeing them further away
so this is the nearby part of the survey
you can you know definitely see some of
the walls and filaments popping in and
out so we're now about three billion
light years away four billion light
years away now we're getting to the
thick part of the survey where we have
we have a lot more data out here this is
kind of the peak of the survey density
and once we get to the edge now the
objects are getting to be faint enough
that we don't get a very high sampling
so with the survey will start to thin
out here as we get out to the edge about
7 billion light years away from us ok
the density so there many more galaxies
in there truly many more galaxies and
we're able to measure we're basically
measuring some representative sample of
them as you move out and that's a
varying number okay well that's
qualitatively that's the map that's the
kind of thing we're that's the map we're
measuring and we now want to try to
analyze it quantitatively to look for
these sound waves the way that we do
this is with something called the galaxy
correlation function so it's a
relatively simple idea pick a galaxy and
sit on it and now count the number of
other galaxies in a ring around that
point now repeat that is a function of
the radius of the ring and then repeat
that picking every other galaxy in the
sample as the center point and sum over
all that and when we're done then in
fact in 2005 we got this first detection
that at a distance of 118 verse
megaparsecs about 150 mega parsec we
found this extra bump in the in the
large scale correlations of galaxies and
this was exciting because it gave us a
four percent measurement of the distance
but it also was what gave us a very
clear connection between this beautiful
physics that we're seeing in the
microwave background with all these
acoustic features in the microwave
background only 400,000 years after the
Big Bang we're now seeing the imprint of
that 10 billion years later in the
cluster
of galaxies so emboldened by that we
started sdss three and one of the major
goals for us to SS three is to use the
acoustic peak to study the evolution of
dark energy we operated sdss three
starting in summer 2008 and ran it for
six years until summer 2014 and the part
of the survey that's relevant to this is
called the baryon oscillation
spectroscopic survey boss and the goal
was to produce a world-leading
detections of the bao over a wide range
of red shifts so the best acoustic think
we have at this point is this one so
this bump at 500 million light years and
basically measuring this bump relative
to the blue line the location of the
bump relative the prediction from the
blue line is what gives us our
measurement of distance and this
actually gives us a one-percent
measurement of the distance to Reggie
2.57 it's the most precise extra
galactic distance get measured well we
do this now at a variety of redshift so
we have our measurement at redshift
point three which is a two percent
measurement we have this one at point
five seven there's another one at
redshift to which I'm not gonna have
time to tell you about and we have also
of course the measurement in the
microwave background itself 14 billion
years ago so when we just plot this in
plot distance versus redshift we have
our points here there's other Bao
measurements from a survey called
wiggles and a survey in Australia called
60f so we actually are now piecing
together the distance versus redshift
relation of the universe by looking at
this characteristic acoustic scale
fingerprint we're just seeing the same
fingerprint at different redshifts and
by measuring the change in angle we're
measuring the distance dial to all these
different redshifts well now let's see
what we can learn about cosmology from
this so i'll start by showing you the
prediction for this curve from the
microwave background data assuming that
the universe is flat and the cotton has
a cosmo and that the dark energy is a
cosmological constant i'll come back to
explain those concepts a minute but so
just making those assumptions you get
this prediction for the curve so you can
see it's an amazingly good match of the
date of the low redshift data
to this prediction from the CMB when we
zoom in if you divided by the center
point of the CMB then you get you you
get this thing and you can see that
we're basically agreeing we're finding
agreement at the two percent level of
the predictions with our measurements so
that's really wonderful to see it and in
detail you know the low red ship date is
an excellent match to this model but of
course we could test other models and so
let's explore some of those tests well
in general relativity one of the major
ideas is that space space is curved and
gravity is basically because gravity we
perceive gravity because this space-time
is curved and in particular the universe
as a whole is curved and you can have
options so the universe could be flat
like a sheet of paper and to Donnie if
it's a two dimensional unit will be flat
like a sheet of paper or of course a
three-dimensional version or it could be
curved like a sphere we could basically
be like an aunt living on the surface of
a sphere that would have curvature or it
can be crinkled like a saddle like or a
potato chip and and you can define
universities like that this curvature
matters because it means that important
things about geometry like the idea that
ass the circumference of a circle is no
longer two pi times the radius this is a
familiar idea if you're sitting on the
if you're sitting on the North Pole and
you walk down to the equator and then
you walk around the equator you will
find that you only have to walk four
times as far as you did from the North
Pole rather than rather than 2 pi as far
so curvature does matter it also has the
effect that angles of triangles the
angles of the 38 the sum of the three
angles of a triangle don't add up to 180
degrees anymore okay well turns out that
the acoustic peak is really wonderful
measurements of this and so if we make a
plot of the density of matter in our
units let's not worry about it but their
units called Omega matter and the
density of dark energy then if those
some to unity along this line then you
would have a flat universe and by just
looking at so if it would som de more
than that you'd have a spherical
universe lesson that would be this this
potato chip or saddle universe so our
data from the from the acoustic
oscillations is really strongly driving
us back
to a flat universe and when we add in
the fact we see the same fingerprint in
the microwave background you get driven
down to this little region here so the
data just seeing the same acoustic scale
at all these different redshifts allows
us to vary dramatically see that dark
energy is there and that that the
universe is very close to flat but of
course we also want to understand about
this dark energy and up till now I've
been saying oh it's it's a cosmological
constant well of course we'd like to
study if it's a cosmological constant
the cosmological constant is saying that
a given volume of space ways some amount
and the amount that it weighs is
invariant with time if you come back
later on it's going to weigh the same
amount but maybe it changes of course
it's very reasonable to think that would
change if i take the universe and it
expands if it expands by a factor of 2
so that the volume is 8 times larger the
cosmological constant is saying there's
actually eight times more stuff because
the volume increased by a factor of
eight that's kind of weird so we'd like
to see if this is changing and we
typically parameterize this by W so W is
minus 1 is the cosmological constant and
values other than minus 1 mean that this
density is changing in time so let's
return to this previous figure that I
showed where before I showed you the red
region and our data but now let's
imagine altering these hypotheses so
we're going to now take the predictions
of the CMB but instead of saying that
the universe is flat we're going to say
that the universe has a 1-percent
curvature and that moves the prediction
down to this blue region not as good a
fit to the data or we could say they'll
know we'll keep it as flat but now we're
not going to assume the cosmological
constant we're going to allow the dark
energy to change in time and in
particular let's pick a dark energy that
has gotten a factor of 2 weaker since
redshift of one and that would give us
this grace woth here again not as good a
fit to the data so the data is really
forcing us back to the flat cosmological
constant model and this is a version of
that same idea where I've now plotted
the curvature so here's flat and the
dark energy density evolution here's the
cosmological constant and the data is dr
back to this blue region so this is very
remarkable we've taken what we thought
was the simplest model a flat
cosmological constant model and we've
opened up two degrees of freedom to new
parameters in the model allowing the
spatial curvature to vary and allowing
the dark the dark energy to evolve in
time and the data is driving us back to
the simple model so it's very
interesting evidence for for that simple
model ok so we've really had a
remarkable few decades in cosmology and
and we now have I think a very concrete
and simple and elegant theory for how
the universe works starting at an age of
one second with the formation of helium
and determined the light elements onto
today on scales from galaxy scales up to
the scale of the observable universe and
its really a triumph that it's been able
to be tested in so many different ways
we have lots and lots of cross checks
lots of confirmations and this theory is
is very important not simply because it
explains these cosmological observations
but because it gives a very robust base
it's giving us it has a very specific
prediction for the initial conditions of
the universe and that allows us to
simulate forward and provides the basis
for all of our studies of galaxy
evolution and and the evolution of
cosmic structure but along the way we've
discovered our this this you know very
elegant theory has two new ingredients
dark matter and dark energy and we don't
know what they are so this is really the
opportunity for the next decade or next
decades to explore these topics to try
to figure out what dark matter and dark
energy are and it's going to be a very
exciting decade because we have a lot of
new facilities that are going to be
improving our maps I work on a project
called desi which is going to be using
the four-metre telescope at Kitt Peak to
do these surveys on even larger scales
there's a big project called the large
synoptic survey telescope which is going
to be imaging the sky every four nights
to build up a very deep map of the
universe there's a European satellite
mission called Euclid which is going to
map the sky in great detail and of
course once you have these maps you want
to
able to go and understand individual
galaxies in that and that's where the
giant Magellan telescope the Jeff
McClintock will tell you about next week
comes in so these these facilities are
just going to bring a very large reach
on cosmology we have the opportunity to
improve these maps by a factor of order
100 over the coming over the coming
decade and you know just get to lots of
interesting new phenomenon in cosmology
so to conclude I hope I've convinced you
that acoustic oscillations are providing
a very robust way to measure the
cosmological distance scale and with
that starting to probe the nature of
dark energy it's based on very simple
physics from the early universe that
leaves a very clean I'll d at week
signature in galaxies clustering and
this method has really matured over the
last ten years to being a very important
tool in our in our study of the cosmic
expansion history with in SPSS we've
used the acoustic peak to measure
distance two percent level accuracy and
we find really excellent agreement with
a flat cosmology with the cosmological
constant and there's lots more to do
because we really want to understand
what dark matter and dark energy is and
so the next generation of astronomers
have a lot of work to do here's my son
making an early suggestion so I'll
invite you to learn more about our
survey at ww sdss org and I'll be happy
to take any questions thank
how do the instruments you're using
compared with the James Webb dance
committee and they're going to launch in
the next few years yeah so on James Webb
Space Telescope is the successor to the
Hubble Space Telescope and it's a
telescope that's optimized for infrared
observations in space it's a very narrow
field telescope so it really looks at
pinpricks of the sky but it looks
enormously deeply and that looks in the
infrared so we're doing wide field
surveys primarily in the optical so
James Bob is extremely important for
understanding of the period the early
galaxies the formation of early galaxies
will be able to dissect really the
evolution of galaxies across a wide
range of cosmic history but ultimately
it only covers tiny fractions of the sky
so it's not it's not as good at napping
things you know you want to map things
but once you find there certain things
you want to go and look at them in
detail yes sir electromagnetic energy
requires no medium for its propagation
my understanding of acoustic energy is
that a medium is required for it to be
propagated oh I'm probably missing
something in your debt well Amelia
mystic so these are these are ways that
are propagating because of the motion of
particles so those particles can move
without a reference to a medium um I'm
not even really sure I mean if we talked
about the air in this room I know if you
look at microscopically I'm not sure you
would say there's a medium you're maybe
thinking that the sound waves are moving
through the air I'm describing the sound
waves as the air the molecules of the
air are actually moving and that's
what's causing the sound wave propagate
but you don't have to really you don't
have to invoke something that the air
that those molecules are moving in you
just think it's space so it's the same
thing here young lady right there
oh how much data and how long do you
think it would take to map the known
universe yeah that's a good question of
course part of the answer depends upon
how finely you want to map if you want
to make crude maps then you get one
answer if you want to make very fun you
get a different answer um we're very
limited in how far we can see so
galaxies get fainter as you go further
away and it makes them harder and harder
and harder so the surveys that we talked
about for the next generation will get
us out to about redshift of three which
is a long way it's a big chunk of the
university but it's not the whole
universe um for those surveys we're
talking about samples of the level of
between 50 million galaxies up up to a
border of billion galaxies and you know
rather long periods of time but to go
beyond that to back even higher
redshifts even fainter things requires
even more ambitious ideas and people
talk about futuristic radio telescopes
on the far side of the Moon and other
ideas like that trying to trying to get
up these these ideas of how to map more
and more of the universe here I thought
the answer was it depends on how big
your Grandpa's when you talk about dark
matter it's been identified since like
1935 I guess bytes wiki that's what
because of the fact that it's displays
gravitational effects on right flank and
galaxy clusters what is the sins in
which you want to call it matter and do
we know that it is particularly
okay that's very good question so I
think it's fair to say that it is just a
moniker so you can imagine different
different different substances that
could be it but it is important i think
the data now at this would not have it
as obvious as wikis time but the data
now very clearly indicates that whatever
this stuff is it's moving rather slowly
so that that actually puts a lot of
limits on what it can be for example is
not it's not massive entry no streaking
around the universe it's actually it's
actually moving slowly now whether it's
a subatomic particle or whether it's
some you know ford fiestas dancing
around the university just you know you
can imagine just lumps of stuff
traveling around you can imagine
primordial black holes for example but
anything that's this that has the
properties that it's cold that's moving
slowly and that if when you when you
increase the size of the when you double
the size of the universe and hence
increase the volume by a factor of eight
that the amount of mass in the Box stays
the same which is what you expect any
type of effort that that's what you need
now we do know that the the stuck is not
our normal stuff and we know that from
the synthesis of elements in the early
universe and also from the measurements
in the microwave background so we know
that the dark matter is not was not
normal protons and electrons in at
either one second after the Big Bang or
four hundred thousand years after the
Big Bang and that puts a lot of that's
what really drives people to think that
it's some exotic particle because you
could Matt you could have imagined that
it would be you know some kind of of you
know cold dark lump of stuff that just
happened to condense but in fact it
didn't you must have condensed before
one second after the Big Bang so you can
talk about black holes but you don't
usually talk about dark stars for
example so it's gotta fit into the
standard model
well or has been session at the Santa
model we know the Standard Model of
particle physics has holes in it this is
and dark matters is I think most
particle physicists think the dark
matter is one of those holes but but
this is not the only hole there's
actually a bunch of balls instead bottle
thanks any questions all right Joker's
back there yes at 400,000 years of what
is the distance between a peak in a
valley in the CMD at 400,000 years
what's the difference between a peak
kind of Ali did I know right actually it
is in fact them yes so it's so that's
right so it's I mean today is 500
million light years so back then it was
500,000 my ears because the universe is
a thousand times smaller you might
wonder how can travel 500 thousand light
years in for two thousand years and the
answer is some of that travel was at
earlier times when he got extra credit
give this expanding Universal things get
travel thank you my god whether those
variations back then correlate or I
believed to be caused by quantum
fluctuations yeah so so the usual theory
of inflation basically the question is
how does how does any dudes get started
I've told you how given some initial set
of perturbations how they evolve the
sound waves all about how they evolve it
doesn't tell you anything about how they
get started and the theory of how they
get started is this theory of inflation
that says that the universe goes to this
early period of a very very rapid
expansion and because of quantum
uncertainties from one part of the
universe to the next different parts of
universe expand by slightly different
amounts so if you take you know if you
take some sheet of paper you try to
expand it really quickly and but you
pull on different parts of different
different rates than the paper will end
up wrinkled and that's those crinkles
are the are the initial perturbations
that then give rise to all the football
the formation of structure galaxies
clusters on these acoustic oscillations
we're going to wrap it up with one
really good question right
out there um so you mentioned that there
is a number of different theories about
dark matter and dark energy the knee of
these theories predict or generally
believe that there's a connection
between dark matter and dark energy the
same way that there is between normal
matter and warmer normal energy
connection between dark matter and dark
dinner yeah so there are theories that
try to connect them I wouldn't say the I
mean most theories leave them separate
but people of course are very
interesting yeah like to find a common
confident explanation of everything you
try to evoke as hbu tooth fairies as
possible so yeah so people are trying to
figure out if there might be a
connection they do behave rather
differently so um you know dark matter
is is basically normal stuff in the
sense that when you expand the universe
the amount of mass stays constant dark
energy has this funny property that when
you expand the universe you get more of
it so it's not immediately obvious that
the two are related but as people would
love to try to find connections okay and
with that we're going to sign off so
please join us again next month thank
you